[Music]
you know I think that what's interesting
is that at times of tumult in the United
States of America the 50s and 60s now
you see candidate sees often to the
center right but sometimes of either
party who come out on this kind of law
and order platform this idea that we
need to regain control of what's
happening or things will will become
chaos right and so it's hot the time
we're in we think the last few years we
have seen riots and in various cities
we've seen angry protest people in the
streets people upset that scares a lot
of people people who aren't comfortable
with that people whose lives were or are
plenty happy and who are comfortable
they don't like the idea that the
freeway shut down they don't like the
idea that people are angry or yelling at
the police officers and what they desire
is someone who's going to come and tell
them I'm going to handle this i'm going
to get things back to the way they were
now there's a false promise there
because the way they were for the way
things were previously was was not any
better we just perhaps weren't paying
attention to it there is always unrest
there are always people who are in pain
they're always protest happening but
we've been in a moment where we've had
an acute awareness of that pain that is
different than the moments previously
and so it's unsurprising you know Donald
Trump becomes one of the the first
candidate since Nixon to so successfully
wield this law and order type of
platform and so while that comforts some
people people on the other end of the
spectrum are horrified by that right
what might that mean if you are the
young black man who's a woman who's been
in the street protesting what might that
mean for you if you're one of these
activists if you're if you are you know
what does he sees invoke things about
you know potential nationwide's
stop-and-frisk which horrifies a lot of
people he's talked about the crackdowns
on immigrants and that horrifies a lot
of people and so there's this
understanding that we have this spectrum
of security and liberty and that will
people's Liberty be taken in order to
provide a greater level of security
because very often in those moments of
fear when we are scared of what is going
to happen and what has happen
our world those end up being the moments
very often where we make historically
some of the worst decisions we've made
as it relates to respecting the liberty
of some of our fellow Americans protest
in and of itself is is a foundational
block of our democracy that this is in
fact before we had the right to vote we
had the right to protest right now that
it's the First Amendment is one of these
it is the first thing that the founders
decided to enshrine in our Constitution
was this idea to petition your
government and not to petition your
government by getting a bunch of money
or by casting a ballot but rather by
raising your voice you have the ability
to petition your government I think that
you know protest serves various purposes
right protest people often we often see
protest and we often especially those
most of the media look at them
dismissively what what do they want what
are they going to get out of this what's
the point what are they really asking
for why didn't they go vote instead and
I think that that largely misses the
point of protest and why people come to
the streets people protest when they
feel is that the other avenues of
democracy have not served them when you
are a young college student in Portland
who voted for Hillary Clinton in a blue
state and that doesn't really matter
have any bearing on who wins or who does
not win the election I don't think it's
unsurprising that so many the
demonstrations we're seeing are in deep
liberal cities within blue states people
whose votes frankly didn't really matter
in terms of the outcome someone who
lives in New York someone who lives in
LA or oakland right Chicago the protest
is a means of a petition your government
protest is a means of community of
taking an individual voice that by
itself might be weak and compounding it
with other voices that now collectively
become strong would the mayor of any of
these cities take the call of the
individual may they would but maybe they
would not with the governor would the
president address one person standing on
the street saying no this is
unacceptable probably not woody address
50 what do you dress 100 or 101 hundred
thousand well perhaps they would right
it's a means of amplifying a message and
this also a means a physical resistance
of saying this thing that is in front of
me whether this is a police shooting
whether this is an incoming
central administration is something that
I object to and that I will not stand
down for and you will have to deal with
me in the political pressure created by
my presence and so I think that protest
is powerful because of the community it
created an of that community can be
birthed all types of activism an
organization that then leads to
long-term change you know i got the
cleveland in december 2014 which was not
long after the decision to not charge
Darren Wilson and Ferguson had been
announced in the decision not to charge
the officer in the death of Eric Gardner
had been announced and as protests were
reading on all these cities there had
also been another shooting that of 12
year old Tamir rice in Cleveland and so
as protests were breaking out in New
York and in st. Louis Cleveland also had
seen this surge of activism and
Cleveland initially wasn't very happy
with this the police handled the
protests pretty well they kind of guided
them they let them March they let them
shut down freeways but the mayor began
receiving all these complaints about it
why was the freeway shut down why did
you let them do this and he called the
press conference to discuss the ongoing
investigations into the shootings and to
the discuss the protest and he said you
know protesting shut down the freeway is
the cost it's the inconvenience of
freedom that that he essentially he went
to bat for the First Amendment rights of
these demonstrators that's something
that we've now seen many more police
departments do follow that model but
Mayor Jackson Frank Jackson in Cleveland
was one of the first to really do this
and I thought it sent quite a message
about the role of protests and democracy
[Music]